the first question that looms over all
others did World War two end in the way
that people had imagined or particularly
did the winning side gain their
objectives
if those objectives are defined in one
particular manner the answer is no and
another yes let's look at the failures
of the Allied causes World War one had
promised us a perpetual peace the
Versailles Treaty was a way to make sure
that the war would end all other Wars
and it failed the League of Nations
failed in World War two there was an
optimism that the Allies were fighting
for the Four Freedoms or they were
fighting for the Atlantic Charter or
that they were going to rehabilitate
Joseph Stalin and the Soviet Union would
be a partner and they would have so much
power these three powerful nations that
they could adjudicate the post-war world
in a positive sense
so then World War two would sort of be
the real war to end all wars these that
was the idea of the UN Charter that of
course was a failure the more people
have been killed in wars since World War
two than the 65 million who perished in
that terrible six year period the United
Nations while some may argue as an
improvement on the League of Nations by
fact that it still exists in the way the
League of Nations became obsolete
and was ended by World War two has not
been able to either provide a moral or
ethical model for governance on a global
scale much less has it been able to stop
wars from breaking out or ending them
when they do break out it is not a
coalition of democratic nations it is a
coalition of often authoritarian
governments in which true democracies
are in the minority and many of its
resolutions hardly or what we would call
classically liberal they're
mean-spirited they're punitive and
they're counterproductive so the United
Nations if that was the
purpose of world war 2 is to make a
perfect peace that failed if the purpose
of World War 2 was to end
authoritarianism especially
totalitarianism then it failed because
think of it this way Britain declared
war in Germany on September 2nd 1939 to
preserve the freedom of Poland and that
is to stop German totalitarianism from
absorbing Poland in the way that it
absorbed Czechoslovakia and in the way
that it had undermined nations like
Romania and Hungary World War two ended
by turning those countries over to the
Soviet Union and so we substituted if I
could be so general and so sloppy and
terminology we substituted a right-wing
totalitarianism for a left-wing
totalitarianism in terms of blood on
one's hands Stalin who had been
knee-deep in the collectivization 's of
the 1920s the show trials the execution
of the Russian military classes of
Polish civilians had more blood on his
hands and Hitler did and yet World War
two ensured that the Soviet Union would
now control Eastern Europe that was not
the objective and so in that way World
War two failed again if the objective of
world war ii however on the other hand
was to stop nazi germany to stop italian
fascism and to stop Japanese militarism
and to prevent them from killing
millions of people it sort of failed to
at least in the sense that it only
stopped them after 50 to 55 million
Chinese Russians Eastern Europeans and
Western Europeans had died in other
words
given the power of the Soviet Union that
was displayed during the war and the
power of the British Empire and the
power of the United States one ask why
couldn't that power have been expressed
earlier in 1938 39 40 and it would have
precluded the axis headstart or at least
their ability to kill so many unarmed
people had the United States had the
military power that it had in 1943 in
1939 had Britain had the power displayed
in 44 had it had that in 36 maybe we
wouldn't have had place names like
Belsen or Treblinka or Auschwitz maybe
six million Jews would be alive today
because the Third Reich wouldn't have
dared try to start a war with such
powerful allies in that sense the
agendas of world war ii were a failure
but that said if the agenda was to stop
a costly mistake that is that prior
European appeasement prior American
isolationism prior Russian collusion out
of naivete self-interest selfishness
laxity any term you want to use might
apply to the attitudes of the Allies
prior to the war despite all-out if they
finally wised up in the case of Britain
in 39 in the case the United States and
41 in case of Soviet Union 41 and they
saw that they were facing an existential
threat in fascism and Nazism and
Japanese militarism and an existential
threat that had a head start and the
purpose was to stop that then World War
two was a success and remember how close
they came to failing